et
[Musique]
le plan d'organisation shadoks de la
terre a raté gégène s'est fâché les
shadoks se sont réfugiés sur la lune
[Musique]
malheureusement la lune était
excessivement pas comporté comme vous le
savez c'était un machin qui montait et
son modèle tourné d'affronter zee et de
façon tout à fait lunatique
[Musique]
vous allez encore dire tout ça c'est des
histoires aussi bien que sur la lune il
n'y a pas d'atmosphère et vous shadoks
là bas ils n'auraient pas pu respirer
eh bien si figurez-vous qu'en ce
temps-là il y avait de l'atmosphère sur
la lune ça oui il y en avait et beaucoup
plus que vous pouvez imaginer
mais cette atmosphère là n'était pas
dehors comme sur une planète ordinaire
non elle était à l'intérieur de la lune
mais vous allez encore pour tester tout
cela ne nous explique pas comment les
pauvres bêtes faisait pour respirer vous
pouvez vous répondre qu'on n'a jamais
dit dans notre histoire que les shadoks
respirait et ça ne serait pas faire plus
alors il y avait des plis plus aucune
portée dans la lune il n'avait pas de
petits tuyaux les percer des trous pour
aller respirer à surface comme les
phoques mais à l'envers
les shadoks n'étaient pas des phoques
alors ils avaient dîné panier atmosphère
individuel
non pas de panier et bien c'est une
vivaient à l'intérieur de la lune
non non vous n'y êtes pas mais puisque
vous voulez décidément encore un vous
explique tout et que vous tenez à tout
savoir
sachez donc que tu aurais pu non vous
saurez la prochaine fois
[Musique]